let's get into audience questions for
the week three really good ones starting
with hey David should prostitution
really be looked down upon by society
isn't it just the job for which people
exchange something of value for money
like everybody else who works I think
it's a little more complicated than that
and but but still I don't really think
we should be looking down as a society
at prostitutes and maybe that's
different than prostitution so first and
foremost most people don't end up in
prostitution because they grew up
wanting to be prostitutes right it's
economic circumstances its
socio-cultural circumstances its lack of
opportunities it's in some cases you
know I don't want to characterize overly
broadly but it can be family situated
right like we can think about different
ways people end up doing that I don't
think that it's something to look down
upon any more than we would look down
upon someone who has figured out a way
to make ends meet for themselves then
you get into the question of okay well
what if what that person is doing is
legal versus illegal and then we have to
remember well crime is definitely a
social construct Society decides what we
say is legal or illegal would society
look at prostitution differently if it
were legal and regulated well maybe but
it's not really a different act in the
same way that is having an ounce of pot
on you morally different if it's legal
decriminalized or legalized I don't
really think it is I mean the criminal
justice system sees it differently but
as a society my opinion of someone who
has an ounce of pot is no different if
they're in a state where it's illegal a
state where it's decriminalized or a
state where it's legalized right I'm
thinking of the action as an action
independent of its legality so that's
that's number one I think it's important
to say yeah I think this stigma that
would be minimized if we made
prostitution legal and maybe you're in
that sense it does differ from marijuana
because I think many of the negative
externalities that go along with
prostitution would go away like pimps
running the things
and making a lot of money from it from
the transmission of STDs and unwanted
pregnancies and all that stuff so in
that sense I can kind of see a
difference so now that we've talked
about how we see the individuals let's
talk about whether prostitution as an
institution is something that should be
looked down upon because what are we
saying when we say listen that the
questioner says people are choosing to
exchange something that has value in
society for money what's the difference
between selling bottled water and
selling sex I think there is a
difference and it's hard for me to
define exactly what it is and I think an
example that's relevant would be the
sale of human organs right you could say
listen if you want to sell a human organ
it's no different than selling
tchotchkes or Barbie dolls or bottled
water it's all exactly the same I don't
know that it really is I think when
you're getting into organs or sex or
some of these other areas you are
talking about something that is in some
way materially different from simply
saying I grill corn on the cob and sell
it from a little push cart at the local
fairs there is something different there
whether it justifies looking down at it
from a societal level I I don't know I
don't really I don't look down at
prostitution I don't but I do recognize
that there is something that is
different about selling your body for
sex and selling organs than just selling
you know groceries or something like
that I don't know how to define the
difference yeah and maybe society will
always look down upon it I mean it's
it's known as the world's oldest
profession right it's been in existence
throughout all of time all of culture
and there's really no way to get rid of
it because even when you make it illegal
the black market comes up so I think
that's thigma if it hasn't left us yet
we'll always be there there probably is
going to continue to be to being stigma
as long as society is organized roughly
the way it's organized now I can imagine
and if you've read a lot of sci-fi you
can probably imagine ways in which
reproduction altogether might be
differently organized that prostitution
kind of becomes not a big deal in the
way that it is now
but I believe that we should not look
down upon prostitution in the way that
society tends to but we can still
identify the circumstances around
prostitution as undesirable and work to
resolve those